what's the first day like writing a
screenplay for you when you have these
different ideas in mind take out because
today was basically one of those days
oh great that's like I just got off the
phone before you came over um you know I
I can't even I mean I it's just throwing
ideas around at first and Chris Prakash
who co-wrote starlit and tangerine he's
wonderful at you know note-taking so
he's there typing away just compiling
every note possible into something I
don't know even know what he's typing
what you know a simple text or something
he's just compiling all these notes so
the first day is really just us
brainstorming spitballing ideas right
but there must be something in you
that's like okay I think I'm ready to
commit a good two plus maybe years of my
life to this and so you you're already
set on the idea yeah and you you know
that you want to do it so then you're
sort of stream-of-consciousness thinking
and he's taking notes and then at some
point how do you formulate that into
like a first page that's really hard to
say because it's over the course of many
months you know so I I think there
there's a point where there are enough
notes down on page and you you
understand your story enough where it's
time to start writing those pages so I
might write a page he'll write a page
we'll start sharing them I know that we
used for both films I think we used
Google Drive and we were sharing a lot
that way you know we also go about it
where we eventually get to a point where
we we have the the post-its on the wall
and that that that's when you when you
actually can get a film or your idea
your you know your script
up on the wall and like with hundreds of
post-its and it makes sense from
beginning to end I think that's when we
decide to start assigning each other
pages and scenes so we'll say okay you
look at that scene I think I got a
handle on that scene I'll take that can
you take that one because I don't have a
handle on that one and then we we share
them and then we start to compile this
thing and that's how that's that's how
that's done what would you say is the
most important part of the screenwriting
process for you whether it's creating
that conflict whatever ten minutes half
hour in to the opening whatever it is
mm-hm the third act yeah that's really a
difficult question would you say you
know the ending I almost always know the
endings of every one of these movies
before we even set down the road to you
know to start breaking it breaking it
out point by point I mean I knew the
ending of starlit I knew the ending of
tangerine I know the ending of the next
film so that's because I just I I think
endings are very important to me
prints the same goes for prints at
Broadway and take-out so with all of
them I knew the ending was almost more
important in the beginning this is the
first time I'm thinking about this sort
of stuff so so I haven't been asked
these questions before so but ya know I
think it's actually I focused more on
the last scene and the impact the last
scene will have that's almost one of the
first things I think about you know with
tangerine it was the only thing we
thought about when I went to you know to
start our research process Chris bruh
gosh and I went to the corner of Santa
Monica and Highland and we started
introducing ourselves to people etc you
know just telling them what we're gonna
do when we finally found my aunt Kiki I
said I only have like a few ideas here
and one of them is well first off it has
to take place on one day because we have
a limited budget and costume changes
cost money and continuity cost money
it's easier to shoot and it's one of the
film that takes place in a 24 hour
period time the second one is that I
think people
coming together or someone's trying to
find somebody else or whether that's a
love story or a revenge story I don't
know and the third is this ending I know
I can see the ending I can see all my
characters converging at the end at
donut time in a big climactic scene
those were the only things I saw going
into it so it's funny yeah it's funny
you say thank you bring that up the
endings are very important to me because
it's about how the audience leaves the
theaters you know III think very much so
about the impact of that last scene if
you think I look at my favorite films
and my favorite films are like Harold
and Maude and when he's walking away at
the end after you know the the car goes
over the cliff and you think he might be
in it but then he's up on the cliff and
he's with this banjo you have you know
something most of my favorite films have
such incredibly memorable lasting scenes
that have an impact on the audience as
they're sitting there during the final
credits and I think that that's
something I'm always conscious out of
it's a it's it's the most important
thing for me in a screenplay
you